aujourd'hui nous allons pêcher les mains
dans un port du Canal du Midi en général
les gens ils font tomber toutes sortes
de choses souvent des outils mais aussi
parfois des objets insolites allez on va
voir ce qu'on y trouve et ici il y a
quelque chose d'assez lourd comme une
corde peut-être
on va voir
on a un leurre de pêche
de vue attends je vais les essayer quand
même je pense que la branche a cassé du
coup elles sont tombés
ah non mec c'est un truc de vieux ça
appelle-moi professeur Ledoux
j'ai fait la branche de la lunette
je pense pas
oh plein d'outils
et une cuillère
voilà comme il y a des prises et tout il
y a peut-être plus d'emplacements
permanent en péniche peut-être un peu
plus de potentiel ah oui un truc
on va essayer de le récupérer quand même
c'est un gilet
OK et
plusieurs choses
non non
police nationale recrutement
regarde mais non
c'est plus une pub action pour une
utilisation professionnelle
l'exigence de la direction
n'a pas de visibilité ne doit pas être
modifié remplacer ou Souilly ou
endommagé il est conçu pour signaler la
présence d'un utilisateur visuellement
quand il est créé par des phares de
véhicule sur les routes sombres oui
c'est pour mettre c'est un truc de la
police
énorme c'est génial et je vais le mettre
je vais recruter pour la police
nationale
cruciforme cette fois
quant à ta sœur
regarde ça regarde ça
une fourchette qui est en très bon état
[Musique]
du pont juste là
il arrête pas de pêcher découvert et il
m'a dit qu'il allait le mettre dans le
lave-vaisselle là il était à deux doigts
de tomber dans le canal mais ce qui
s'est passé que je vais faire la
découverte de la journée maintenant
ça il le sait pas encore
un iPhone avec la vidéo de pêcheur de
trésor en train de tourner
oh
mais il y a que le bout alors qu'est-ce
qu'on a
regarde voilà
ça c'est ça qu'on veut mais oui
des ciseaux en bon état
une fourchette en bon état
un couteau en bon état et ça le couteau
le marteau bah ouais il y a que la tête
encore une fourchette et un couteau
mais c'est dingue aujourd'hui
hop là et une fourchette
non c'est une cuillère je comprends mais
j'ai un truc là j'ai quelque chose
un drôle de bruit en arrivant
un truc
[Musique]
orange
j'ai vu quelque chose
c'est pas un piqué ça
oh il y a une corde
pas très grande
je sens peut-être quelque chose
ah oui oui il y a vraiment un truc bien
vu François Quentin
on est tombé sur quelque chose de très
gros et bien dans la base surtout donc
on va aller chercher le treuil et ça
part on va sortir ce qu'elle a dedans
ouais ben là c'est lourd
allez une tente de voir les bulles pour
nos petits bras
c'est dur à dire peut-être un vélo bah
c'est le plus logique on va dire ça peut
être un barbecue on a déjà fait un hamac
aussi en faire ça y est ça bulle
en face dès le début
après moi ça vient
ça vient ça vient les hommes forts
il est pas aussi mauvais état
par contre
incroyable concerné par la base
c'est rare que tous les rayons ouais
[Musique]
j'ai quelque chose
je crois que c'est quoi
en plus tu peux texter
moi je teste
un détail pour le coup
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est sur un spot
magnifique très prometteur qui nous a
été conseillé par un abonné donc un
grand merci à toi tu te reconnaîtras
voilà bah on est venu on a réussi à se
faufiler un chemin c'était pas facile
d'accès et là on a déjà quelque chose
première lancée OK
pour l'instant
mais l'autre côté
il y a plein de bois
l'ombre
caisse de magasin mais tu vois le bord
il nous gêne de ouf et oui
c'est le problème de ces carrières pas
très accessible
c'est bon signe ça mon petit si si
tu crois
OK
non
j'ai fait une Baptiste
j'ai besoin de toi
tu nous as fait quoi de beau là
[Musique]
il va bientôt retomber je pense on va
pas se passer
c'est bon
sans déconner
[Musique]
non non
c'est parti
il y a quoi
[Musique]
on n'a pas fait des gros truc encore ça
c'est quoi
je vois pas ce que c'est ça
viens
sacre
au début
de la carrière on va prendre le deuxième
est mort parce que là on a un gros
morceau
et c'est vers l'autre côté là
une mauvaise journée du coup une journée
cadre de scooter
ça c'est vraiment
bon cette deuxième carrière nous réserve
bien des surprises parce que on a autre
chose
ok c'est pas un cadre
non mais on va finir par le nettoyer cet
endroit enlever tous les petits bouts
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi du coup
bizarre
[Musique]
moi aussi je crois
alors voyons voir
mais j'ai besoin du deuxième aimant là
juste en bas
tranquille
c'est la mascotte
ah ouais ouais on doit trouver des
choses aussi
il y a des choses intéressantes parfois
[Musique]
en général ça fait peur des fois parce
que ouais les animaux c'est sûr c'est
pas top mais c'est
ça nous est jamais trop arrivé nous dans
l'eau au final
bizarrement
[Musique]
dans l'eau aide-moi
il est énorme
[Musique]
merci bonne journée
deux lieux assez insolites pas assez
ordinaire
n'est-ce pas monsieur
on est content et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche à l'aimant et oui c'est
comme ça que ça marche les pêcheurs de
trésor
et pendant ce temps restant
à son habitude en détente
qu'est-ce que c'est